well cbs news medical contributor dr
david agus joins us from los
angeles david good morning let's start
with the vaccine
and speed safety and logistics are at
everyone's you know
top shelf right now what are some of the
challenges when we're talking about the
possibilities
so we have phase three trials ongoing
for several vaccines in the united
states and several that have actually
begun months ago
outside the united states and other
countries those data are looked at
literally weekly where we see is there a
difference between a group that got
placebo
and the group that got the vaccine if
there's a statistical difference
and as well as a safety indicator they
will go and file that data with the fda
that data will be transparent every
citizen will see that data and be able
to make a decision on a vaccine
the drug companies actually are getting
together now and saying we're only going
to file
if the data merit it so this will rise
above politics science will win here
nobody knows when there will be enough
cases to show
that we actually have a vaccine that
works but again
science will win we heard a lot of
warning about previous summer holidays
and how people handled them and sort of
letting their guard down
we are in a holiday weekend but we're
also entering
flu season as well what did we learn and
what are we concerned about at this
point
back to school season holiday weekend uh
uh temperatures going up across the
country you know i am worried obviously
you know from other holidays we get
together more families friends
and that could be spread of the virus we
have to continue
social distinct wearing a mask and the
behavior changes that we all know will
stop the virus it's not only for
ourselves it's for our community
if one doesn't wear a mask they can
spread the virus so we all have to do it
and i can't emphasize enough that we
have to be in this together
david the largest school district in the
country new york city did delay
opening but they are going to go back
now in just a couple weeks here
they're implementing a testing program
where more than 10 percent of students
and staff will be tested once a month
is that the right strategy
well 1.1 million students 75 000
uh teachers even at 10
to 20 that's a large number of tests it
could be the right strategy if the
results come back very quickly and they
can contact trace
because if you find a student or a
teacher that's positive it's who do they
interact with
and those people have to obviously be
quarantined for 14 days
so if the policy really is a
testing with quick results and contact
tracing
i think they have a shot to actually do
something meaningful with educating
these kids in person
all right dr david agus as always thank
you very much